- [voiceover] Point O is the center
of both circles in the figure above.
If the circumference of
the larger circle is 36,
so the circumference of the
larger circle there is 36,
and the radius of the small
circle is half the radius
of the larger circle, what is the length
of the darkened arc?
If you have half the radius,
you're going to have
half the circumference.
We could even solve for
what that radius is.
You want to know what the
radius of the larger circle is?
The larger circle, we could
say, two pi times its radius
is equal to 36, and so its radius,
if you divide both sides by two pi,
it's radius is going to be equal to,
36 divided by two is 18 over pi.
That's the larger circle.
The smaller circle has a radius
half of the radius of the larger circle.
The smaller circle's radius is, so radius,
and I'll write a little
sub S there for the radius
of the smaller circle is
going to be half this.
It's going to be nine over pi.
The circumference of the smaller circle,
the circumference of the
smaller circle is going to be
its radius, nine over pi times two pi.
Pi divided by pi.
You're going to have nine
times two is equal to 18.
The circumference here is 18.
It might have already jumped out at you
because circumference is
directly proportional to,
because circumference for any circle
is directly proportional to a radius,
if you have half the
radius, you're going to have
half the circumference and you would not
have to go through all of this.
You could've said, "Hey,
okay, if I have a radius here
"of 36 and if I have a
circumference here of 36
"and if I have a circle
with half the radius,
"its circumference is going to half that."
It's going to be 18.
That's not what they're asking us.
They're not asking us
just the circumference
of the smaller circle.
They're asking us what is the arc length.
What is the arc length of
this part right over here?
This 80 degrees.
80 degrees, remember,
to go all the way around
the circle is 360 degrees.
This is 80/360 of the entire
circle right over here,
or the entire circumference.
If you want that arc
length, it's going to be
the circumference times
80/360, times 80 over 360.
That's the same thing as, let's see,
then divide both of them by 10.
That's the same thing as 8/36.
Let's see.
You can divide eight
divided by four is two,
and then 36 divided by four is nine.
Then you are left with, let's see,
18 divided by nine is
two, so you're left with
two times two is equal
to four, and you're done.